bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'apple on va parler de l'iphone 8,8
plus version red red steel association
qui lutte activement contre le vih un
partenariat avec apple depuis de
nombreuses années très intéressant
justement temps d'en parler
m
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'apple apple tout simplement parce
qu'ils ont lancé un nouveau projet sont
pas vraiment un nouveau produit comme
tous les enfants du monde comme l'année
dernière et puis quelques années son
partenariat avec red alors raid c'est
une association qui lutte contre le vih
et cette année apple a sorti plein plein
plein de produits à rien effectivement
l'iphone 8 l'iphone 8 + version red à
l'épaule l'ipod touch est pas mal de
choses et là je vais vous en parler
parce que la question à se poser c'est
est-ce qu'il faut acheter ses produits
red est ce qu'ils sont intéressants
parce qu'il ya un intérêt et oui ou non
alors après c'est super embêtant parce
que c'est quand même pour la lutte
contre le sida donc tout de suite si on
dit non on culpabilise
on va voir si c'est bien oui ou non
alors ici enfin petit brief rapide je
suis à nantes à nantes pour le boulot et
j'en ai profité des sur pour emmener ma
caméra pour pouvoir filmer au besoin
s'il ya des choses et là je vais vous
montrer je suis dans un petit airbnb que
j'ai joué donc je suis chez l'habitant
dans une jolie maison
là c'est ma jolie petite salle de bain
mouillés moi bonjour c'est par ici que
vous faire visiter vite fait un peu les
coins avant de vous parler un peu plus
de ce nouvel à la fin de cet iphone 8
iphone 8 plus de cette série elle je
vous faire marrer parce que
fondamentalement lorsque je bosse ils
ont fiché peut-être mais lorsque je
bosse bouffe très très très mal regardé
je suis là pour dix jours ça c'est ma
bouffe pour dix jours autant vous dire
que lorsque je bouffe à toi au rosmeur
le pôle génial vraiment des trucs
dégueulasses saas et les salades du midi
c'est vraiment dégueulasse
ces données c'est pas terrible mais bon
sinon je suis pas mal ici vous avez un
petit peu petit peu fort sympathique mon
ordi wells est le seul canton radio
c'est l'obligation la poubelle déjà bien
remplie tu as des quelques jours je suis
là et là c'est moi alors au final est ce
qu'il ya un intérêt à acheter ses
produits alors c'est super emmerdant
parce que si vous voulez on est quand
même un peu dans la culpabilité parce
que red forcément c'est quelque chose de
plutôt pas mal d'associations qui est
écrit en 2006 par bono puis parlera pas
mal de deux personnes différentes qui a
permis de récupérer
selon apple plus de 160 millions d'euros
de dollars 160 millions de dollars donc
c'est quand même relativement énorme
pour la lutte contre le vih donc
fondamentalement
l'idée en tout cas l'essence même de ces
produits red il est vachement
intéressant alors après est-ce qu'il
faut y aller aujourd'hui oui ou non est
ce qu'il faut acheter ça moi je suis un
peu regardé parce que si vous voulez
l'iphone 8 et 8 plus que vous avez que
la collection red vous le retrouviez
déjà il ya quelques temps donc ils ont
probablement déjà été achetés par les
gens qui est intéressé par ces produits
là et surtout ce qui est super emmerdé
enfin bon c'est qu'à la fin de l'année
en fin du mois de septembre je
m'embrouille c'est le matin ce qui peut
arriver au mois de septembre c'est que
vous allez avoir de nouveaux produits à
le ch a salué le chat vous allez avoir
de nouveaux produits vous allez avoir
l'iphone dix nouvelles versions de balle
édition qui va sortir et a priori deux
nouveaux iphone un iphone plutôt low
cost est un iphone s2 voir ce qui va
être présenté aux d'apple ou d'abeille
ou dc et puis un autre iphone à la fois
un peu plus grand iphone 10 plus donc
c'est ce qu'on devrait avoir cette année
donc est-ce que ça beaucoup tout de
suite d'aller acheter un iphone 8 64
giga à 809 euros je suis pas sûr et un
iphone 8 + 64 giga à 919 euros
je suis pas sûr non plus si vous avez
déjà un iphone un téléphone qui est pas
très très vieux et que vous pouvez
attendre un petit peu pour moi je vous
dirais attend dès le mois de septembre
et fait un don à une association pour la
lutte contre le vih parce que ça a
vraiment un sens et pour le coup c'est
bien et il faut le faire vraiment voilà
ça c'est de mon point de vue après si
vraiment vous voulez un produirait si
vraiment cette coque elle est vraiment
belle
elle vous plaît vraiment vous savez
envie de l'acheter vous pouvez y aller
l'iphone 8 allée phone 8 plus sont
d'excellents produits vous avez les
puces à 11 qui marche très très bien la
puce bionic est vraiment super la bonne
performance de les mêmes performances
que vous avez dans l'iphone 10 alors
effectivement pas de faille ça y est il
n'ya pas les caméras trou de m c'est
quelque chose comme ça que vous n'aurez
pas dedans mais par contre vous serez
pas déçus parce que le produit en lui
même est vraiment bien ça c'est pour le
premier point en plus il importe qui est
super sympa c'est que l'année dernière
je pas si vous vous rappelez vous l'avez
déjà parlé mais lorsque vous regardez
cet iphone 7,7 plus version rack et est
sorti ce qui était vraiment ce qu'on
regrette énormément c'est qu'il y avait
une phase une façade avant qui était
toute blanche en fin du mois le contour
l'écran ce n'est pas avec le dos rouge
l'apprend coup cette année ils ont
vraiment voir amélioré la sauce et ils
vous ont sorti un contour noir avec le
dos rouge qui est vraiment magnifique et
lapointe coup le produit il est sublime
j'adore ça je pense que la couleur
vraiment elles se marient super bien
donc ça c'est vraiment un joli pouces
c'est vraiment mieux que ce qu'ils ont
fait l'année dernière
l'iphone 7,7 plus le 8 puis plus c'est
vraiment jouer donc si vraiment ça vous
plaît et govou l'iphone 8,8 plus vous
pouvez y aller sans aucun problème
ensuite vous avez toute la gamme vous
avez les bracelets pour la watch le
bracelet règles pour moi je le pense les
blacks sadry brasse les règles qui
existent
vous avez les smart cover vous avez les
coques coque en cuir quand silicone pour
les iphone vous avez la couverture comme
je le disais pour l'ipad vous avez des
batteries batteries pour recharger vos
smartphones en version red
il ya aussi l'ipod touch rennes il ya le
casque beats raid de 10 ans entre n ya
pas mal de choses en raid donc ça c'est
vrai c'est plutôt pas mal fichu on va
pas se mentir c'est plutôt bien réussi
donc si vous voulez acheter un produit
red qu'il vous plaît si vous avez besoin
d'un de ses produits il avait pas
l'acheter pour l'acheter si vous n'avez
pas besoin est ici le la cause vous
plaît allez faire un don à une
association de lutte contre le vih que
ce soit elle en france ce soir rennes
aux us regardant le monde fait ça ça
peut avoir un sens maintenant voilà la
question allait là dessus si vous avez
besoin vous pouvez y aller vous n'avez
pas besoin
faites un don à une association et
attendons plutôt de voir ce qui va se
passer du côté du mois de septembre pour
apple parce qu'à mon avis y voir des
choses yvon grave déchirer alors comme
je le disais la chute à nantes du parti
faire petit rouage temps là la banlieue
de notes en proche banlieue de nantes
je travaille pour dijon dans quoi et
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour passer un
petit message à quentin du 78 tu m'as
envoyé un petit message sur snap salue
quand un car tu vas bien et justement je
vais vous montrer ce faire un petit tour
vous allez voir un push bossent ici le
temps est un petit coup ça va mieux et
il pleut moins c'était vraiment
dégueulasse ces derniers jours reste ça
va quand même beaucoup mieux regarder la
voilà enfin j'ai pas les apports la tête
j'ai prévu la capuche un corner je vous
montre un petit peu ce que je fais où je
bosse aller voir ses coûts la direction
expo nantes sais pas si vous vous
souvenez
si vous avez suivi j'étais venu l'année
dernière alors la dernière ce n'était
pas du tout pour le table c'était pour
le hellfest
je sais pas si vous avez suivi ma vidéo
du hellfest elle fait c'est un festival
de dingue c'est un des plus gros
festival de métal européen le plus gros
français avant avec le download qui
arrivait à l'année dernière
sandra parle pas on va parler que du
hellfest j'y retourne cette année vous
allez voir c'est un truc complètement
ouf abonnez vous parce que vous allez
voir pour voir vraiment ce marais sasaki
son ca coûté 90
là je suis pas du tout pour ces raisons
c'est pour le taf
si beaucoup moins sexy
bien bossé tout aussi c'est bien beau de
s'amuser mais bon voilà c'est cool donc
rester connectés comme on dit parce que
vous allez voir le hellfest on y
retourne et puis je vous invite à
retourner voir la vidéo du fps de
l'époque parce que franchement ça
envoyer du bois
[Musique]
la viande tient bon à la favorisation
invitation solution belle prestation à
vos seins
là je vous présente carole au jour qu'un
vol ba carole voilà c'est la fin de la
journée on à la caméra qui par un peu
henry oui ça va ça va ça va bon ça va on
a dit et ça j'aimerais bien travailler
aujourd'hui carole oui je fais le plus
beau qu'avant mais surtout lié pour deux
regarde regarde c'est toi la caméra pour
regarder ici là tu dis bonjour à tout le
monde alors je dis bonjour à tous et
s'il bat la bassée qui accroche de dire
qu'elle découvre un petit peu donc là
dessus et sur youtube qui parle à tout
le monde à peu près trente mille
personnes qui vont te regardes et tu
fais bonjour comment vous allez bon jour
bon ça va aller très très très très
douce car ils pas des membres est menacé
par mois qu'il faut le dire un bon ça va
on a bien travaillé aujourd'hui ça pique
un fard les mâles ans les mâles
voilà pour cette fin de journée alors
information là il est quelque chose
comme 19h50 c'est plutôt pas mal
aujourd'hui
bonne journée de taf vous avez vu un
petit peu ce que je fais j'ai présenté
quelques collègues et rapidement
donc voilà la question se pose en tout
cas pour cet iphone 8 iphone 8 plus
raide savoir s'il faut l'acheter au
mieux non après à vous de voir un peu ce
que vous en pensez vous de marquer tout
seul a commenté vous me dites ce que
vous en pensez pas ce que c'est vraiment
un sujet très très très intéressant et
particulièrement assez passionnant si
vous avez sportif ça devoir croiser une
sportive s'est rapidement
[Applaudissements]
et les gens qui courent déjà hyper
motivés sais pas ce que vous en pensez à
ce que vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
par ce iphone 8 puis de plus ce modèle
raid et puis toute la collection que ce
soit les brevetés pour les watch
lesquels les protections l'ipod touch et
tout le toutim
voilà vous marquez tout ça en
commentaire merci beaucoup regardez moi
comme c'est mignon tout ça à côté de
nantes c'est une super joli comme
endroit
si vous êtes dans le coin je suis encore
là pour quelques jours donc marquer moi
des commentaires contactez moi sur
twitter sous les venir faire la fête
voilà merci à tous soyez sages à très
bientôt
mark et moi bien sûr en commentaire ce
que vous en pensez et puis rester
connecté on laisse des jolies pouces on
s'abonne toussa toussa toussa
quant à moi je vous dis à très bientôt à
demain pour une nouvelle vidéo
ciao
[Musique]